[Music]  the unique reflections quest is about  inspiration  are we ready here we go at mazda the  inspiration behind unique reflections  started with the way we approach our car  design  there's a depth there it's not a flat  surface and it's meant to reflect the  world around you in a way that's unique  so this assignment is meant to challenge  these storytellers  use reflective-based servicing to tell a  story it's about not only a literal  interpretation  but also finding ways that you can  reflect upon who you are as a person and  as a photographer  it's not easy to know when to take the  shot it gets a little disorienting  it's even harder to know how to use  reflection in an image  so right now i'm bouncing off of this  tricky part is not getting myself  in this as you're taking pictures of the  people and how they see the world  make sure that we can understand how you  see the world as well  [Music]  you